dear candidate we usually only hire
people with
stellar gpas yours is obviously not that
great so why do you think you even have
a chance of working here you're a young
graduate fresh out of university
how will you be able to add value to a
senior client
you do not seem to have done much beyond
your academic achievements so are you
just a boring person
has any of you ever had a question in an
interview which really made you
uncomfortable so this is something that
some people like to call a stress
interview so an interview where your
interview partner deliberately
tries to put you under stress in this
video i will talk about stress interview
situations how you can prepare yourself
the framing of this video is stress
interviews and job interview situations
but of course you might also face stress
interviews in
other instances for instance when you're
facing a hostile client
which might ask you questions that put
you under stress so welcome to another
video on firm learning my name is
heinrich i'm a former mckinsey
consultant
and on my channel i try to help you to
become successful in the first years of
your career the video will be structured
in the following way so first i will
provide a bit of context on stress
interviews so do these
really happen is this what you need to
expect when you sit in a consulting
interview or maybe also an
interview for another type of role or
position in another company and then i
will share three tips or reflections
of how i think about stress interviews
and what you can do
to prepare and handle the situations in
the best way so let's
first talk about the context does this
really happen will you need to sit in a
stress interview when you apply to
consulting and here the good thing for
you is actually that
many firms have policies to not do this
so i know at least for germany
that the mbb firms so mckinsey bcg and
bain
usually do not do job interviews for
their interview situations but of course
the truth is also that interview
cultures
differ by region and of course also by
firm so it might be that in some firms
you
are facing these situations and for sure
outside of consulting there are firms
where this is taking place so you better
be prepared because
even for mbb firms often especially the
later stage interviews i conducted by
partners or senior partners
and they do have some flexibility of how
to conduct these interviews
so i would never be sure that this is
not something that might happen to you
as well so better be prepared for this
so what is the why
why might people decide to do that why
is anybody putting you in such a stress
situation at all and here it might be
helpful for you just to take a step
back think about what these interviews
are trying to test after all anyway and
i would argue that the number one
question that consulting firms want to
answer when they interview you is
is this person able to potentially next
week
be with me on a team at a client
potentially very early on in the first
one two or three weeks
sit alone with a client in a room having
a conversation
with this person be able to handle it
well
to represent the firm way this is the
main question that consultants will ask
themselves when interviewing candidates
in case interviews
in personal fit interviews and any other
conversations that are taking place
during interviews
and here it is just the truth that in a
client environment if you are a
consultant
you will face stressful situations where
clients will try to go after you will
try to attack you
will try to put you under stress
situations like this
literally happen every single week on
most
projects you will regularly sit together
in meetings with clients where these
clients might have a different agenda
than you have maybe they don't like the
project
maybe they have a general bias against
consultants
maybe they don't like you and they will
take everything that they find to make
you look
bad in front of others to put you in a
stressful situation
to question your competence to question
your work results and of course this is
not
only the case as a consultant but things
like that happen in almost every company
this is what is called politics after
all right but i would argue that as a
consultant you're a little bit more
prone to situations like this
compared to other people are just
regular employees of that company now to
close the circle right this is the
reason why this might be tested in
interviews the interviewer might be
interested to see how you react
if somebody tries to put you under
pressure so this is why it's done this
is why it's tested and this is now a
great transition to my three reflections
and tips on how to handle these
situations and my number one tip is to
understand the intention
why are people doing this because many
candidates if you are in an interview
situation with them and this is
happening to them
they feel personally attacked they feel
like oh this interviewer does not like
me apparently this interviewer doesn't
want to hire me and they instantly get
nervous get defensive and so on but this
is of course not the intention in almost
all of these situations in the vast
majority of cases you can assume your
interviewer to be a professional after
all because indeed think about it the
fact alone that you are sitting in the
interview
means that you passed the first
screening right so the cv screening so
clearly your cv is considered
good enough to work at this company so
if any interviewer is implying that
maybe your gpa
just to pick this example is not good
enough for the job obviously he or she
cannot be serious because otherwise you
wouldn't have been invited to the
interview
if your cv would not have been good
enough on paper so tip number one
understand this this is not about an
attack but it's a test
understand the intention of why this is
happening now my second reflection is on
what to do so how should you respond to
that and here i say that
even more important than what exactly
you say is how you
say it many people who get such a
question will
instantly turn defensive they will be
nervous they suddenly will start to
speak
much faster their head will turn red and
so on right and of course i understand
that this is very difficult
and especially in a stress situation
that an interview
per se already is if then you're facing
such a thing it's really
difficult to control yourself but the
first step to improve is to at least
intellectually understand what you
should avoid and for sure do not be
defensive
do not perceive this to be an attack but
rather try to continue the conversation
in the very same tone of voice in the
very same body posture
just as you behave before this question
was asked because after all this is
exactly what ideally you would be able
to do in front of a client as well you
don't want the conversation to escalate
into any weird direction whenever you
get a comment that potentially catches
you off guard you want to be perceived
as handling this
professionally as finding a very calm
and to the point answer to that and not
instantly getting nervous and this is
exactly the confidence that you should
at least try
to radiate so if you are able to do this
this is almost already everything that
then the interviewer will be looking for
and then of course
try to also say a couple of things that
make sense now again the gpa example
when somebody's accusing you of the gpa
not being good enough you can just say
that yes you acknowledge that
potentially other people might have
higher gpas but you still believe right
that you have other things that you can
bring to the table then maybe you can
mention a couple of other achievements
in your academic life and other areas of
your life that from your perspective
might compensate for that
again i strongly hope that what exactly
you say isn't even that
important but rather how you say it but
before we jump into it i want to
introduce you to the sponsor of today's
video
and this sponsor is skillshare
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of classes for
creative and curious people you can
explore new skills
deepen your passions and get lost in
creativity there are classes on
marketing personal branding
presentation skills and many more all of
these are topics that are highly
applicable to a career in consulting
banking or corporate and the best thing
is that i made a slight writing class
for skillshare so you can access and
enjoy it as a skillshare member
personally i recently took the class
productivity master class
principles and tools to boost your
productivity from the fellow youtuber
ali abdal
it's a great class it taught me many new
aspects of productivity and i very much
enjoyed how you applied the pareto
principle or the 80 20 rule to
productivity
classes on skillshare are specifically
curated for learning there are no
ads they're always launching new premium
classes so you can stay focused and
follow wherever your creativity takes
you and the best thing is that it's less
than ten dollars a month with an annual
subscription skillshare created a
special offer for subscribers of this
channel from learning and so the first
thousand subscribers of me click on the
skillshare link in the video description
we get a free trial of the skillshare
premium membership i hope this helps you
to explore your creativity
check it out link in the video
description now my third tip is
practice because the number one reason
why usually seasoned consultants will be
quite good
at defending comments like this in
client situations and so on
is not because they are geniuses or
super great at this from the beginning
but because they already experienced
situations like this in a very very
frequent way
and if this happened to you lots of
times then it's not even a big deal to
you anymore
you know how to handle it you know how
to reply and the very same thing is true
for job interviews so if you never
thought about that this might happen how
you would react
if you've never experienced anything
like this of course it will be extremely
difficult than to react and reply in the
right and correct way so my tip would be
that you try to expose yourself to these
kinds of situations so if you still have
a couple of years before you really
apply
try to get yourself into a leadership
position into an operational role
maybe at an organization the social
course that you really care about
at your university try to get some
things done there collect some
leadership experience because in these
settings you might also face situations
like this
maybe people attack you have another
agenda than you
and this is a great playground just to
develop these skills if this is already
too late and now you're really just a
couple of days weeks or months before
the interview
then maybe try to role play these
situations with another person where he
or she deliberately
asks you questions like this and then
you try to respond and then another way
how you can practice this probably
especially applicable for introverts
like myself is rather to play around
these situations in your head so try to
imagine
sitting in such an interview situation
think about some questions that the
other person might ask you that will
really catch you off guard
and think about how you would react how
your blood pressure and piles would
increase
how you will feel uneasy not really
comfortable how you would feel scared
that maybe this is now the end of your
interview
try to really visualize all this and
then try to relax
and think about how you could find a
good answer to that i'd argue that if
you really mentally go over these
situations in a regular way
this will also potentially help you to
handle these situations
right in an actual setting in an
interview so i'd love to hear from you
now did you
ever experience difficult situations
like this in job interviews or when
sitting with clients or other business
partners let me know in the comments i'd
love to hear from you i will do my very
best to answer
every single comment and of course
comments also help me with the youtube
algorithm so if you took any value out
of this video at all
please hit the like button for the
youtube algorithm
and also subscribe to this channel to
stay up to date on all my content i'm
releasing weekly videos
every single saturday also i have an
instagram my handle is firm learning so
check that out as well if you're
interested
to see more from me and also want to say
thanks again to the sponsor of this
video skillshare so check out the link
to skillshare in the video description
for this free trial period and of course
as always a big thank you to the members
of firm learning you're really helping
the course of this channel
so thank you so much for your support so
again next video will come out next
saturday so thank you all have a good
weekend
this is heine from from learning cheers